This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Today I'm really excited to bring you the beginning of a new mini-series that we've been working on for the past year. It's called Not Built For This, and it's about climate change, but in a very 99PI kind of way. It's not really about the science or CO2 projections or electric cars. This series is about how our world was not designed for the tectonic changes that are coming. From top to bottom, our society is full of structures and systems that are being stress tested by increasingly extreme weather.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。今天我非常高兴为大家带来我们过去一年一直在制作的新迷你系列的开篇。它叫做《非此之料》，是关于气候变化的，但带有非常浓厚的 99PI 风格。它其实不是关于科学、二氧化碳预测或电动汽车的。这个系列讲的是我们的世界并非为即将来临的地壳剧变而设计。从上到下，我们的社会充满了经受着日益极端天气压力测试的结构和系统。
The series is going to cover infrastructure and insurance, housing and public health. Over the course of six episodes, we're going to take you all over the United States, to Florida, California, Louisiana and Arizona. But today we're going to start with a small story set in an unlikely state. If you had to make a list of the states you thought were relatively safe from the worst impacts of climate change, Vermont might be close to the top. The Green Mountain State is relatively cool, there's plenty of water, it's nowhere near the ocean. It also happens to be the state where Emmett Fitzgerald, the host of our series, grew up. He's from Montpelier, a quaint little town
这个系列将涵盖基础设施与保险、住房和公共卫生。在接下来的六集里，我们将带你走遍美国各地，去到佛罗里达州、加利福尼亚州、路易斯安那州和亚利桑那州。但今天我们要从一个以意想不到的州为背景的小故事开始。如果你必须列出一个你认为相对安全的、免受气候变化最严重影响的州，佛蒙特州可能会名列前茅。绿山州相对凉爽，水资源充足，而且离海洋十万八千里。它恰好也是我们这个系列的主持人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德长大的地方。他来自蒙彼利埃，这是一个古雅的小镇，
that's also somehow the capital city. And it's truly the last place that I ever imagined starting this series. But then something happened last year that made everyone in Montpelier understand that they might not be so safe after all. And so to begin, I want to take you to the little town that I know best in all the world, and explain what happened. This is episode one of Not Built For This, the bottom of the bowl. Bear Pond Books is a small town institution in Montpelier, Vermont, and a place where I've spent a lot of time.
同时它不知怎么的还是首府城市。这确实是我从未想过要在这个地方开启这个系列的地方。但去年发生的一件事让蒙彼利埃的每个人都意识到，他们或许并没有那么绝对安全。因此，首先，我想带大家去我全世界最熟悉的小镇，并解释发生了什么。这是《非此之料》的第一集，“盆地之底”。“熊池书店”是佛蒙特州蒙彼利埃市的一个小镇标志性机构，也是我度过很多时光的地方。
It's the kind of store that wants to be lingered in. It feels full, almost overstuffed, like the opposite of an Apple store. It smells like old paper. And when I was growing up, it had these delightfully noisy wood floors. You could hear every step that every customer took inside that store.
这是一家让人想久久流连的店。它感觉满满当当，几乎塞满了书，就像苹果店的对立面。它闻起来有旧纸的味道。在我成长的时候，它有那种令人愉悦的木质嘎吱地板。你能听到店里每个顾客的每一步脚印。
Yeah, pretty much everyone was like, oh, you can't sneak around in here. You know, we heard that a lot. And I said, yeah, that's our that's our analog security system. This is Rob Casso. He owns Bear Palm with his wife, Claire. And Rob says that the bookstore is probably best known for two things. Their pet tortoise, Veruca,
是的，几乎每个人都说，哦，你在这里可没法鬼鬼祟祟的。你知道，我们经常听到这样的话。我说，对，那是我们的模拟安全系统。这是罗布·卡索。他和妻子克莱尔一起拥有“熊池书店”。罗布说，这家书店最出名的可能是两件事：
has a little unfortunate habit of making serious love to his rocks. And those creaky wooden floors. Like an older person, you know, you get creaky when you get older. It's like you got bad knees if the floor was in that state. But those floors are gone. The store's signature floors were removed in the summer of 2023, after Bear Pond Books, along with nearly every other business in downtown Montpelier, was inundated in a flood.
他们的宠物乌龟乌鲁卡有一个不幸的小习惯，就是对他的石头疯狂示爱。还有那些吱呀作响的木地板。就像老年人一样，你知道的，老了就会咯吱作响。就像地板处于那种状态，你就会膝盖不好。但那些地板已经不在了。在“熊池书店”以及蒙彼利埃市中心几乎所有其他企业被洪水淹没后，这家店标志性的地板在2023年夏天被拆除了。
Record-breaking weather, the catastrophic flooding impacting communities across Vermont. Vermont officials say they've had to rescue a hundred people who are trapped by the worst flooding in a century. Cars floating down streets, windows of businesses looking more like fish tanks, the water nearly as high
破纪录的天气，灾难性的洪水影响了佛蒙特州各地的社区。佛蒙特州官员表示，他们不得不救援了一百名被一个世纪以来最严重洪水困住的人。汽车在街道上漂浮，商铺的窗户看起来更像是鱼缸，水位几乎和城市的停车收费表一样高。
as the city's parking meters. Parts of Vermont received two months worth of rain in just two days. All that water trickled off the hillsides and into the rivers that run through Montpelier. And eventually there was just too much of it. The Winooski and the North Branch spilled their banks and poured into the town. If you were in Montpelier that day, you would have heard this eerie orchestra. Every security system on Main Street going off all at once.
佛蒙特州的部分地区在短短两天内降下了相当于两个月的雨量。所有这些水从山坡上倾泻而下，流入穿过蒙彼利埃的河流。最终水实在太多了。威努斯基河和北支流冲垮了河岸，倾泻进城里。如果你那天在蒙彼利埃，你会听到这种诡异的交响乐。主街上的每一个安全系统同时响起。
I called up my parents on the day of the flood. I am. And it turns out that in the middle of this big disaster, they were dealing with a smaller one. Watson just gets skunked right in the middle of all of this. Watson is the family dog, and he had just been sprayed by a skunk. For what it's worth, I didn't really realize quite how much everyone in my family swears until I started recording these phone calls. Anyway, I can't be here. I'm trying to mix up a mix for Jeff who's outside
我在洪水发生的那天打电话给我父母。我是说。结果证明，在这场大灾难中，他们正在处理一个小麻烦。沃森就在这一切正中央被臭鼬喷了。沃森是家里的狗，它刚被一只臭鼬喷了粘液。不管怎样，直到我开始录制这些电话之前，我其实并没有意识到我家里的每个人有多爱说脏话。总之，我不能呆在这儿。我正忙着给杰夫调配一盆药水，他在倾盆大雨中陪着那条该死的混蛋狗。
in the pouring rain with that fucking asshole dog. As my mom was mixing up the old family skunk solution for the asshole dog, my dad came back in from the rain. I got to get a dog and everything's not fine. It's really not fine. In the grand scheme of things, my parents were, in fact, fine. Their house is way up on a hill, well outside the danger zone. But the last few weeks of weather had been surreal.
当妈妈正在为那条混蛋狗调制家里祖传的臭鼬驱味剂时，爸爸从雨中回来了。我得弄只狗，而且一切都不好。真的很糟糕。从宏观角度来看，我父母其实没事。他们的家在很高的小山上，远远超出了危险区。但这几周的天气简直太超现实了。
First, the town had been blanketed in wildfire smoke that had blown down from Canada. And then came the endless rain. I will just say, it is fucking weird the last three weeks of weather. The smoke, the haze, the humidity, the lack of sun, the amount of rain. It is not like anything I've really ever experienced.
首先，小镇被从加拿大吹来的野火烟雾所笼罩。接着就是没完没了的雨。我只想说，过去三周的天气简直邪门透顶。烟雾、阴霾、湿气、缺少的阳光、雨量。这跟我经历过的任何事情都不一样。
Each one independently would be one thing, but to put them all together in the last month is just enough to make you kind of go, whoa. Before the town had even dried out, experts were already saying that this flood was not going to be a one-off, and that Montpelier should expect more storms just like it as the climate continues to change. The science here is pretty simple.
每一项单独拿出来都算是一回事，但把它们在过去的一个月里全都凑到一起，就足以让人忍不住感叹，哇哦。甚至在小镇还没干透之前，专家们就已经在说，这场洪水不会是孤立事件，随着气候继续变化，蒙彼利埃应该预料到会有更多这样的风暴。这里的科学原理很简单。
Warmer air can hold more water. And so as the temperature of the atmosphere increases, so does its capacity for deluge. But even though it was predictable, I think getting hit with a climate disaster came as something of a shock to the people of Montpelier, including me. I distinctly remember reading this ProPublica story back in 2020. It ranked every county in America based on climate risk, and I was relieved to scroll to the bottom and see that six of the ten least risky counties in the entire country were in Vermont. I've been reporting on climate change for long enough to know that it will impact every corner of the world.
较暖的空气可以容纳更多的水。因此，随着大气温度的升高，其暴雨承载能力也在增加。但尽管这是可预见的，我认为遭遇气候灾难对蒙彼利埃的人们来说还是相当震撼，包括我在内。我清楚地记得在2020年读过这篇《ProPublica》的报道。它根据气候风险对美国每个县进行了排名，当我滚动到最底部时，我感到一阵释然，发现全美风险最低的十个县中有六个在佛蒙特州。我报道气候变化的时间足够长，知道它会影响世界的每一个角落。
But still, I think I internalized this idea of Vermont as a climate safe haven. I always thought of the Little Green Valley where I grew up as a place where I might go when things got really bad out in California where I live now. But then my Little Green Valley filled up like a bathtub. When the floodwaters finally receded, my parents headed down the hill to help with the cleanup, and they were shocked by the damage. The entire downtown was a muddy mess. Homes in low-lying neighborhoods were totally swamped, and an army of volunteers was piling
但我认为，我依然内化了“佛蒙特州是气候避难所”这种想法。我一直认为我长大的绿山小谷是一个当我现在居住的加州情况变得真正糟糕时我可以去的地方。但随后我的绿山小谷像浴缸一样被水填满了。当洪水终于退去时，我父母下山帮忙清理，他们被眼前的破坏惊呆了。整个市中心成了一片泥泞的烂摊子。低洼地区的住宅彻底被淹，大批志愿者在街上堆积残骸，展开了一场与时间赛跑的疯狂竞赛，以防止霉菌滋生。
debris on the streets in a frantic race to prevent the mold from setting in. My dad ended up at Bear Pond, where he found Rob throwing out merchandise. The books, it was painful. And they're heavy when they're really wet, too. So it was really hard, nasty work. But the books were just the beginning. Over time, Rob realized that the shelves were unsalvageable, as were the tables. And sadly, the beloved wood floors had to go too. They ripped out those squeaky old boards, and replaced them with something more waterproof.
我爸爸最后到了“熊池书店”，他发现罗布正在扔掉商品。书本，这太痛苦了。而且它们真的很湿的时候也很重。所以这是非常艰苦、肮脏的工作。但书本只是开始。随着时间推移，罗布意识到书架已经无法挽救，桌子也是如此。遗憾的是，备受喜爱的木地板也保不住了。他们拆除了那些吱呀作响的老旧木板，换成了更防水的材料。
This is the actual sound of the old floors getting sawed out. It's from an Instagram video the store posted, along with the caption, Goodbye squeaky creaky floors. And there are a lot of comments on this post, a lot of sad face emojis, a lot of people reminiscing about their squeaky creaky childhoods. I know the floors aren't that important
这是锯掉旧地板的真实声音。它来自书店发布的一段Instagram视频，配文是：“再见，吱呀作响的地板。”这条帖子有很多评论，有很多悲伤的表情符号，许多人在回忆他们吱呀作响的童年。我知道在地大物博的宏观层面上，地板其实没那么重要，
in the grand scheme of things, but I think ripping them up is the kind of choice that we're all going to need to make a lot more of in the years ahead. Unsentimental choices that are not nostalgic for the world we once lived in and that no longer really exists. And I think I think that kind of change is very hard for people. But I think we're at a moment in our history where things are going to have to change quite a bit. Rob says that keeping everything the same just doesn't really feel like an option at this point.
但我认为拆掉它们是我们未来几年都需要做出更多选择的那种选择。这是不带情感色彩的选择，不再对我们曾经生活过、且如今已不复存在的那个世界抱有怀旧之情。我想这种改变对人们来说非常艰难。但我认为我们正处于历史上的一个时刻，事物将不得不发生相当大的改变。罗布说，在这一点上，保持一切原样实在说不上是一个选项。
A lot of the business is downtown rebuilt with more waterproof materials, but new flooring on its own isn't going to be enough. Not even close. Fundamentally, Montpelier has a geography issue, a kind of climate change Achilles heel, which is that the town was built at the bottom of a bowl at the confluence of two rivers. It's flooded before. But if the area is going to keep getting rainstorms like the one in 2023 or rainstorms that are even bigger, its location could become an existential problem. Or as my dad put it on our call, we might be.
市中心的许多企业都用更防水的材料进行了重建，但仅仅换新地板是远远不够的。差得远呢。从根本上说，蒙彼利埃面临着一个地理问题，一个类似于气候变化的阿喀琉斯之踵，那就是这座小镇建在一个由两条河流交汇而成的盆地底部。这里以前也发过洪水。但如果该地区继续遭遇像2023年那样甚至更大的暴雨，它的地理位置可能会成为一个生存危机。或者就像我爸爸在电话里所说的那样，我们可能也是。
Meaning what? Meaning the community is not situated right for climate change. What are we going to do? Move? I think my dad's frustration is something that a lot of people can
什么意思？意思是这个社区并不适合应对气候变化。我们打算怎么办？搬家吗？我想我爸爸的挫败感是很多人能够感同身受的。
relate to. All throughout the country, people are watching the places they love change in unpredictable and scary ways. Places that once felt safe are starting to feel risky. Places that already felt risky are starting to feel downright dangerous. And as the climate continues to change, people are being forced to make impossible decisions
在全国各地，人们正看着自己热爱的地方以不可预测且可怕的方式改变。曾经让人感到安全的地方开始变得充满风险。本就充满风险的地方开始变得彻头彻尾的危险。随着气候持续变化，人们被迫在日益不稳定且陌生的世界里，对如何生活以及在哪里生活做出不可能的决定。
about how to live and where to live in an increasingly unstable and unfamiliar world. We are surrounded by a world that was built for weather and conditions that were more or less, you could take them for granted for centuries or millennia. This is the writer Alex Steffen. He's someone who's helped me make sense of this bizarre moment that we're living through. And he says that the human world as we know it developed during a relatively peaceful blip
我们被这样一个世界所包围：它是为那些几个世纪或几千年里或多或少可以被视为理所当然的天气和条件而建造的。这就是作家亚历克斯·斯特芬。他帮助我理解了我们正在经历这个诡异的时刻。他指出，我们所知的世界是在地质历史广袤长河中一段相对平静的插曲中发展起来的。我们建造的每一座城市、设计的每一栋建筑、铺设的每一块地板，都发生在地球波澜壮阔的传记中一段相当温和的章节里。我们创造了整个社会来适应我们星球那个美好稳定的版本。但问题是，我们真的不再生活在那个星球上了。
in the vastness of geologic time. Every city we built, every building we designed, every floorboard that we laid, it all occurred during a fairly mild chapter in the Earth's otherwise tumultuous biography. We created a whole society designed to fit that nice stable version of our planet. But the thing is, we don't really live
我们已经建造了一个不再适合我们所居住的星球的世界。对蒙彼利埃或任何地方来说，挑战在于我们如何让我们的城市或小镇更好地适应我们现在所处的现实气候。亚历克斯说，那些尚未领悟即将到来之事的严重性的人，有时说起话来好像这会很简单。比如，我们会变得更有韧性一点。哦，我们会适应的。我们会在这里经历一个小小的过渡，然后一切都会好的。
on that planet anymore. We have built a world that is no longer suited to the planet we live on. And the challenge for Montpelier, or for any place really, is how do we make our city or town better suited to the reality of the climate that we're living in now? Alex says that people who haven't grasped the magnitude of what's coming sometimes talk as if that's going to be easy. Like, we're going to become a little more resilient. Oh, we'll adapt. We'll have a
不，不会好的，这也不会是一个小过渡。不管你愿不愿意，这将需要我们做出一些非常重大的改变。道路在哪里，建筑物如何建造，在哪里建造，基础设施如何运作，城市本身的资金如何运转，人们如何获得保险。所有这些事情都可能需要进行非常深刻的变革，就像对这个社区本身进行重新构想和重建一样。
little transition here and then things will be fine. No, they won't be fine and it's not going to be a little transition. Like it or not, it's going to require us to make some really big changes. Where the roads are, how things are built, where they're built, how the infrastructure works, how the financing of the city itself runs, how people are able to get insurance. All of these things may require really profound changes, like a re-imagining, a re-founding of that community itself.
这种改变真的很难，尤其是当世界已经在你的脚下发生变化，你所有的本能都告诉你应该固守阵地，紧抓那些感觉坚实稳固的东西时，这也是为什么蒙彼利埃接下来发生的事情让我如此惊讶。大家能请往这边挪一下吗？
And that kind of change is just really hard, especially when the world is already shifting beneath your feet, and all your instincts are telling you to dig in your heels and cling to what feels solid and firm, which is why I was so surprised by what happened next in Montpelier. Could I ask folks to move to this side if you can?
房间这边的座位还很多。很高兴看到大家来。真是人山人海。就在洪水爆发大约一个月后，蒙彼利埃的人们聚在一起，组织了一系列关于“恢复与韧性”的主题论坛。数百人挤在山顶的佛蒙特学院老建筑里，试图弄清楚我们究竟该何去何从。所以这是一个非常紧张、沉重的夜晚。
There's still plenty of seats on this side of the room. Nice to see folks coming in. What a crowd. Just a month or so after the floods, people in Montpelier got together and organized a series of forums on, quote, recovery and resilience. Hundreds of people packed into the old Vermont College building at the top of a hill to try and figure out where the hell do we go from here. So this is a very intense, weighty night.
它之所以沉重，不仅是因为数字，还因为我们此时此刻内心所承载的东西。像这样灾难过后的会议通常遵循着相当可预测的剧本。很多美好的团结，很多关于团结一致、重建小镇以及把一切恢复原貌的谈话。但这绝对不是蒙彼利埃这次会议的氛围。人们似乎近乎完全接受了这样一个现实：小镇无法以同样的方式重建并仅仅祈求好运。
It's weighty not just because of the numbers, it's also weighty because of what we're carrying in our hearts right now. Post-disaster meetings like this one usually follow a fairly predictable script. A lot of beautiful solidarity and a lot of talk about coming together, rebuilding the town and putting things back exactly as they were. But that was distinctly not the vibe at this meeting in Montpilier. There seemed to be near total acceptance that the town couldn't rebuild the same way and
他们需要范式转变。这场会议基本上是一场全镇范围内的头脑风暴，提出了各种异想天开的提议，探讨蒙彼利埃如何自我转变以应对当下。我听说1850年代的芝加哥太靠近水面了，他们用千斤顶把整个市中心抬高了多达15英尺。我只是随便说说。有人建议放弃市中心所有建筑的一楼。有个家伙站起来，甚至想把整个小镇搬到会议所在的那个山顶上。
just hope for the best. They needed a paradigm shift. And the meeting was basically a town-wide brainstorm of almost whimsical proposals for how Montpelier might transform itself to meet the moment. I have heard that Chicago in the 1850s was too close to the water level and they raised the entire downtown up to 15 feet with jack screws. Just saying. Someone suggested abandoning the first floors of all the buildings downtown. One guy got up and wanted to move the entire town to the top of the hill where the meeting was taking place
我们应该想出一个计划，基本上就是说，随着时间的推移，把蒙彼利埃市中心搬迁。也许搬到这里来，或者如果不是整个小镇，至少把高中搬走。我们的高中在洪泛区，它被淹了，而且还会再次被淹。我建议我们把高中卖掉，把高中搬到我们今天所在的这个地势高且干燥的地方，为我们的孩子和我们的社区做点实事。说实话，听到那么多人为这个建议欢呼，我真的有点震惊。
We ought to come up with a plan which basically says let's over time move downtown Montpelier Maybe up here or if not the whole town at least the high school Our high school is on a floodplain it flooded and it's gonna flood again I suggest that we sell the high school move the high school up here where we are today because it is dry and high, and do something for our kids and our community. I was honestly kind of shocked to hear so many people cheering that suggestion.
我本来真的以为会听到嘘声。我是说，我差点自己都发出嘘声了。那可是我读的高中啊。我在那个洪泛区踢过很多场足球赛。我还在那栋大楼里写过一篇关于《呼啸山庄》的不赖的五段式作文。然而，如果我把自己的情感暂时放在一边，我并不确定蒙彼利埃能否承担得起忽视这样宏大而不舒服的提议的后果。
I was genuinely expecting boos. I mean, I almost booed myself. That's my high school we're talking about here. I played a lot of soccer games on that floodplain. I wrote a decent five paragraph essay about withering heights in that building. And yet, if I put my own feelings aside for a second, I'm not sure that Montpelier can afford
论坛结束后，镇上成立了一个每两周开会一次的委员会，试图找出蒙彼利埃如何适应气候变化的对策。到目前为止，诸如搬迁高中之类更夸张的想法还没有得到太多的支持。人们希望慢慢来是可以理解的。我懂。我不希望我最喜欢的小镇发生任何超出绝对必要范围的改变。
to just ignore big uncomfortable proposals like that one. After the forums, the town established a commission that meets every other week to try and figure out how Montpelier can adapt to climate change. So far, the more extravagant ideas like moving the high school haven't gotten a lot of traction. There's an understandable desire to move slowly. And I get that. I don't want my favorite little town to change any more than is absolutely necessary.
但与此同时，如果它改变得不够快，将会发生什么，这也让我感到有些惊恐。就好像宇宙正竭尽全力来证实我的恐惧一样，仅仅几个月后，小镇又遭遇了一场倾盆大雨。这一次，12月的气温异常高达58华氏度，因此温暖的雨水将早期的季节性积雪从山上冲刷下来，涌入河流。我在加州难以置信地看着这一切的发生。
But I'm also kind of terrified about what happens if it doesn't change fast enough. And as if the universe was trying its damnedest to confirm my fears, just a few months later, the town was hit with another torrential downpour. This time, it was a freakish 58 degrees in December, and so the warm rain washed the early season snowpack off the mountains and into the rivers. I was watching this whole thing play out from California in disbelief.
我知道夏天淹没蒙彼利埃的风暴只是气候变化发出的第一记警钟。但我没想到第二记警钟来得这么快。在电话里，我父母显得神情恍惚。我只是不敢相信它又发生了。你知道的，这简直是……嗯，我们知道它会发生的。我知道。它会发生，并且发生，并且发生，并且发生，并且发生。是的，太快了。太突然了。
I knew that the summer storms that flooded Montpelier were just climate change's first shot across the bow. But I didn't expect the second shot to come quite so soon. On the phone, my parents seemed dazed. It's just that I can't believe it's happening again. You know, it's just... Well, we know it's gonna happen. I know. It's gonna happen and happen't believe it's happening again, you know, it's just... We know it's gonna happen.
最后，蒙彼利埃躲过了一劫。很多地下室都进水了，但雨停了，就在河水再次淹没市中心之前，水位开始回落。几天后，我回到家，和家人一起过圣诞节。第一天，我们带着狗去山上散步。此时距离7月的洪水已经过去将近六个月了。
I know. It's gonna happen and happen and happen and happen and happen. Yeah, too fast. Too soon. In the end, Montpelier dodged a bullet. A lot of basements got wet, but the rain stopped and the rivers started receding right before they flooded the downtown all over again. A few days later, I was home, visiting my family for Christmas. On my first day, we took a walk up the hill with the dog. By this point, it had been nearly six
许多居民仍然住在受损的房屋里，试图弄清楚他们的下一步行动。我父母说市中心才刚刚开始恢复正常。许多企业最近重新开业，但也有其他企业决定卷铺盖走人。还有许多人仍然处于两者之间的某个尴尬状态。我妈妈对蒙彼利埃这个州首府居然还没有邮局感到尤其沮丧。完全太荒谬了。然后我们的银行花了很长时间才重新开业，但它居然是在一辆拖车里开业的。它现在还在拖车里呢。
months since the July floods. Many residents were still living in damaged homes, trying to figure out their next move. And my parents said that downtown was only just getting back to normal. A bunch of businesses had recently reopened, but others had decided to pack it in. And many were still caught somewhere in between. My mom was particularly frustrated that Montpelier, the state capital, still didn't have a post office. Totally wild. And then our bank took forever to open up again, but it only opened up in a trailer. It's still in a trailer.
但能有市政厅、银行、邮局、酒类专卖店，感觉就像是重要的一点也不重要，酒类专卖店。我们把它删掉吧。这是一个小镇最基础的组成部分。没错，我当时就是这种感觉。在我离开家之前，我顺道去了“熊池书店”。里面挤满了购物的人。尽管我得说，没有了那些吱呀作响的声音，这里安静多了。
But to have City Hall, the bank, the post office, the liquor store, it felt like the import, not important, the liquor store. Let's take that one out of it. The fundamental pieces of infrastructure for a town. Exactly, that's exactly how I felt at one point. Before I left home, I stopped in at Bear Pond Books. It was humming with shoppers. Although I will say it was a lot quieter without all the squeaks and creaks.
有人提到过地板吗？每个人都提到了地板。每个人。我是说，每一个走进这里的人都会说，哦，我想念旧地板的吱呀声了。罗布似乎对前一周的暴风雨没有再次将他们淹没感到宽慰。有些水流进了地下室，但没有引起太多问题，因为他们不再把东西存放在那里了。
Has anyone mentioned the floors? Everyone mentions the floors. Everyone. I mean, every single person comes in here and says, oh, I missed the creaks of the old floors. Rob seemed relieved that the storm earlier the week before hadn't flooded them out again. Some water got into the basement, but it didn't cause too many problems because they're no longer storing stuff down there.
市中心的许多企业实际上也是如此。大洪水过后，许多房东将暖风机、锅炉和其他公用设施搬到了地面以上。为了让空间再次做好应对进水的准备，小镇做了大量的工作。但当我们交谈时，罗布并不确信“熊池书店”能在另一场洪水中幸存下来。不，我们距离下一场洪水只有一步之遥。你知道的，我的意思是，我不认识谁能在明年夏天的洪水中挺过来。我会我半开玩笑地对某个人说，我说，如果再次发洪水，我就会带着我的狗、我的猫和我的妻子上车，然后一直开下去。
This is actually true of a lot of the businesses downtown. After the big flood, many of the landlords hauled their furnaces, boilers, and other utilities up above ground. The town has done a lot of work to prepare spaces to get wet again. But when we talked, Rob was not convinced that Bear Pond could survive another flood. No, we're all one flood away. You know, I mean, I don't know anybody who could come back from a flood next summer. It would be I I jokingly told someone, I said, if it floods again, I'm just gonna get in my car with my dog and my cat and my wife and just keep going.
今年夏天蒙彼利埃还没有发洪水。我在录音时正敲着木头祈祷，但佛蒙特州的其他城镇就没有那么幸运了。7月份的一系列灾难性风暴摧毁了诸如平菲尔德和林登维尔等附近的城镇，留下一整个疲惫不堪的州，再次收拾残局。我认为佛蒙特州过去一年所经历的事情，象征着气候变化在这个国家的许多人身上是如何展开的。它已经从一个谈论、阅读和为之焦虑的话题，变成了一个我们不得不亲身经历的非常不好玩的现实。
Montpelier hasn't flooded yet this summer. I'm knocking on wood as I record this, but other towns in Vermont haven't been so lucky. A series of catastrophic July storms devastated nearby towns like Plainfield and Lindenville and left a state full of very tired people to pick up the pieces yet again. I think that what Vermont has gone through this past year is emblematic of how climate change is unfolding for many people in this country. It's gone from a topic to talk about and read about and get anxious about to a very
气候变化是全球性问题的绝对定义，但它正在引发一系列极具地方色彩的危机。无论你走到哪里，情况看起来都有些不同，尽管最严重的影响还在后头，但它正在颠覆生活，甚至在我们一直认为安全的地方也是如此。在这个系列中，我们将探讨气候变化如何在我国创造出一个全新的风险格局。
unfun reality that we are all just living through. Climate change is the very definition of a global problem, but it's causing a series of deeply local crises. It looks a little bit different wherever you go, and while the biggest impacts are very much still to come, it is upending lives right now, even in places that we always thought of as safe. In this series, we're going to explore how climate change is creating a new landscape of risk in this country.
因为每个地方都有其脆弱性、其弱点，而气候变化被证明极其擅长找出这些弱点。我将我们对这场危机的反应视为一个减少伤害的故事。我们并没有冲向悬崖。没有哪个日期是我们所有人都会死去的。我们正在与时间赛跑以阻止气候变化。但无论我们从现在开始做什么，我们将在余生中都不得不应对它的影响。
Because every place has its vulnerabilities, its weak spots, and climate change is proving to be exceptionally good at finding them. I think about how we respond to this crisis as a harm reduction story. We're not hurtling towards a cliff. There is no date after which we all die. We are in a race against time to stop climate change. But no matter what we do from here on out, we will be dealing with its impacts for the rest of our lives.
因此，我们必须尽最大努力为一个我们只能隐约看清的动荡未来做好准备。我们必须试着弄清楚如何在为自己创造的这个可怕的新星球上生存下去。因为现在，我们都生活在一个根本不是为此而建造的世界里。当我们回来时，将播出周五发布的新一集节目预告。
And so we have to try our best to prepare for a turbulent future that we can only vaguely make out. We have to try to figure out how to get by on the terrifying new planet that we're creating for ourselves. Because right now, we're all living in a world that was just not built for this. When we come back, a preview of our next episode, which comes out on Friday.
好吧，我回来了。我是埃米特。在报道这个关于我故乡的故事时，我采访了一些部分因为气候变化而搬到蒙彼利埃的人。现在，洪水过后，我认为蒙彼利埃在未来几年究竟是一个人们会迁入还是迁出的地方，还是一个未知数。这很大程度上取决于小镇适应得有多好。但尽管佛蒙特州过去一年经历了这一切，从气候角度来看，佛蒙特州依然有很多优势。因为水太多通常总比水不够要好。
Okay, I'm back. This is Emmett again. In reporting this story about my hometown, I talked to people who moved to Montpelier in part because of climate change. Now, after the floods, I think it's an open question whether Montpelier is a place that people migrate to or away from in the years to come. A lot will depend on how well the town can adapt. But despite everything the state has been through this past year, Vermont still has a lot going for it from a climate perspective. Because having too much water is usually better than not having enough.
是的，我是说，从这个星球上人类生命诞生之初，人们就去有水的地方，离开没有水的地方。这是阿布拉姆·拉斯加登，《ProPublica》的气候记者。他实际上就是我多年前读过的、根据气候风险对全国各县进行排名的那篇文章的作者。最近，阿布拉姆出版了一本名为《在路上：
Yeah, I mean, from the beginning of human life on this planet, people have gone to where there is water and left the places where there is not. This is Abram Lusgarden, a climate reporter at ProPublica. He's actually the person who wrote that article I read years ago that ranked all the counties in the country based on climate risk. More recently, Abram published a book called On the Move,
变热的地球与美国的人口大迁徙》的书。和这个系列很相似，它完全是关于气候变化如何影响我们在这个国家的生活方式和地点的。为了这本书，阿布拉姆试图估算美国究竟有多少人可能需要因为气候变化而搬迁。这个结果对我来说相当震撼。因为气候变化而搬迁。这个结果对我来说相当震撼。他采访了研究被称为“人类宜居生态位”的研究人员。基本上，就是那些
The Overheating Earth and the Uprooting of America. And much like this series, it's all about how climate change is impacting how and where we live in this country. For the book, Abram tried to estimate just how many people in the US might need to move because of climate change. And the results were pretty shocking to me. because of climate change. And the results were pretty shocking to me. He talked to researchers who study what's called the human habitability niche. Essentially, the climatic conditions
适合人类生存的气候条件。研究发现，人类生活在一定的温度和降水范围内，在过去的6000年左右一直如此，而这个生态位正在移动。它正在远离赤道，向两极移动。在美国，这意味着向北，远离美国深南部的州，朝着佛蒙特州、
that are hospitable to human life. And it's found that people live in a certain range of temperature and precipitation, and they always have for the last 6,000 years or so, and that niche is moving. It's moving away from the equator and towards the poles. In the US, that means north, away from states in the deep south and towards states like Vermont
密歇根州和纽约州北部等州移动。随着宜居带的移动，它正在抛弃数以百万计的人，数以千万计的人。我们估计它将以某种方式影响大约1.6亿美国人，大约是我们的一半。这并不意味着所有人都会真正搬家，但这确实是他估算中戏剧性的最高值。
and Michigan and upstate New York. And as that zone of habitability moves, it's leaving millions of people behind, many millions of people. We estimate it'll affect about 160 million Americans in some way, so about half of us. That doesn't mean all of those people will actually move, but it was the dramatic high end of his estimate.
但在低端，有研究估计，仅海平面上升就会导致大约1300万美国人流离失所。这就是本世纪可能沉入水底的房屋中居住的人数。现在，1300万远少于1.6亿。但试想一下“大迁徙”，当时有六七百万黑人离开了吉姆·克劳时期的南方，这迄今为止是美国历史上最大规模的移民潮。
But at the low end, there's research that estimates that about 13 million Americans would be displaced by sea level rise alone. That's the number of people living in homes that will likely be underwater in this century. Now, 13 million is a lot less than 160. But consider for a second the Great Migration, when somewhere between six and seven million black people left the Jim Crow South, which to date is the largest migration in U.S.
阿布拉姆所说的人口大规模流动至少是那个数字的两倍，潜在地甚至会大上许多许多倍。没有办法知道这会对我们的文化产生什么影响，或者在我们经历完这场转变后我们的身份会是什么，但这绝对明确地告诉我，我们正朝着巨大的改变迈进，我们不会认出在这次过渡结束时我们所抵达的那个版本的国家。本周五在《非此之料》节目中，我们将一窥那个未来，
history. Abram is talking about a mass movement of people that's at least double that and potentially many, many times bigger. There's no way to know what that will do to our culture or what our identity will be at the end of that transformation, but it tells me with absolute certainty that we're headed for great change, that we won't recognize the version of the country that we arrive at at the end of this transition. This Friday on Not Built For This, we have a small window into that future,
一个气候移民的微型缩影，以及一个关于当你没有为此做好准备时会发生什么的警示故事。我们将前往加利福尼亚州奇科，看看当气候危机与住房危机碰撞时会是什么样子。我的职业生涯中从未见过如此糟糕的住房市场。这就是灾难发生前的状况。我们当时在教授关于气候变化的内容，我真的必须承认，奇怪的是，我当时把它当成了一个未来的问题。
a preview of climate migration in microcosm and a cautionary tale about what happens when you aren't ready for it. We're going to Chico, California to see what it looks like when the climate crisis and the housing crisis collide. I've never seen a housing market in my career that bad. So that was a situation before the disaster. We were teaching about climate change, and I really have to admit that strange thing was that I was thinking of it as a future problem at that time.
它在很大程度上是面向未来的，你知道的，也就是以后会发生的事情。而当那场大火袭来时，它就像咆哮着来到了我的后门。管理疏散到我的后门。对整个天堂镇进行强制疏散。让人们现在就开始行动。然后我想，天哪，
It was kind of very oriented towards, you know, what was going to happen down the line. And when that fire hit, it just kind of came roaring up to my back door. Managing evacuation to my back door. Man- mandatory evacuation to all of Paradise. Get people moving now. And I went, oh my goodness,
大约有3.5到4.5万人流离失所。我放声大哭。身处一个原本住房就如此艰难的行业，然后又遭遇这种事情打击你的社区，简直是太残酷了。本周五即将播出的节目来自 99% Invisible 的《非此之料》。《非此之料》的这一集由我、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，以及制片人杰森·德莱昂、索菲·科特纳和执行主编德兰妮·霍尔共同报道和制作。
somewhere between 35, 45,000 people have been displaced. I burst into tears. To be in a business where housing was that difficult to start and then to have that kind of thing hit your community was just, it was brutal. That's coming this Friday on Not Built For This from 99% Invisible. This episode of Not Built For This was reported and produced by me, Emmett Fitzgerald, along
克里斯托弗·约翰逊、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆以及我们无畏的领导罗曼·马斯提供了宝贵的进一步编辑。混音和声音设计由马丁·甘萨尔负责。主题曲和原创音乐由乔治·兰福德创作。附加音乐由天鹅雷尔提供。事实核查由利兹·博伊德负责。系列美术由亚伦·内斯特设计。本周特别感谢我的父母总是接听我的电话。也感谢罗布·卡索在非常艰难的时期为我腾出时间。你可以在我们的网站上找到亚历克斯·斯特芬的时事通讯和阿布拉姆·拉斯加登的书籍链接。
with producers Jason DeLeon and Sophie Kottner, and managing editor Delaney Hall. Further invaluable editing from Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, and our fearless leader, Roman Mars. Mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez. Theme and original music by George Langford. With additional music by Swan Rayal. Fact checking by Liz Boyd. Series art by Aaron Nestor. Special thanks this week to my parents for always picking up my calls. And to Rob Casso for making time for me during a very tough period. You can find links to Alex Steffen's newsletter and Abram Lusgarden's book on our website.
我还想感谢蒙彼利埃所有为本期节目接受我采访的人。其中包括劳伦·赫尔、埃莱娜·马哈利、保罗·科斯特洛、卡莎·兰霍、埃玛·戴尔、琼·哈维尔·杜瓦尔牧师，以及世界上最伟大的自行车店兼越野滑雪店“洋葱河户外”的老板詹和基普·罗伯茨。《非此之料》是 99% Invisible 推出的六集系列节目。新剧集将会在 99PI 订阅源中推送给你，
I also wanted to thank all of the other people in Montpelier who I talked to for this. That includes Lauren Hurl, Elena Mahali, Paul Costello, Kasha Ranjo, Emma Dale, the Reverend Joan Javier Duval, and Jen and Kip Roberts, owners of the greatest bike shop slash cross country ski store in the world, Onion River Outdoors. Not Built For This is a six part series from 99% Invisible. New episodes will be coming to you in the 99PI feed
每周二和周五更新，你可以在任何地方收听播客。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔stedt是我们的数字总监。99PI 团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、维维安·莱、拉沙·马顿、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳和尼娜·波图克。99% Invisible 的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。99% Invisible 的标志是由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作的。
on Tuesdays and Fridays, wherever you get your podcasts. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstedt is our digital director. The rest of the 99PI team includes Chris Barube, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madon, Gabriela Gladney, Jacob Maldonado Medina, and Nina Potuck. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence.
我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的新 Discord 服务器上找到 99% Invisible。在 99pi.org 上有指向该服务器以及 99PI 和《非此之料》每一集的链接。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
We are a part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. You can find 99% invisible on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that and every episode of 99PI and not built for this at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的新 Discord 服务器上找到 99% invisible。在 99pi.org 上有指向该服务器以及 99PI 和本期节目的每一个链接。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。